hi this is presh talwalkar
last week the ted ed youtube channel
presented the frog riddle which is a
variation of a classic probability
problem
however in telling the story they
included a slight detail which would
actually change the calculation
in this video i'm going to present what
i consider to be the correct calculation
i'm going to go over a simplified
version of the riddle with pertinent
details
i'm going to explain how it relates to a
classic probability problem and one of
its variations and i'm going to show why
the ted-ed video actually meant to do
one calculation but they presented a
story for another calculation
so here's the
riddle imagine you have a population of
frogs that are equally likely to be male
and female and you cannot visually tell
the difference between the genders
you see two frogs
what is the probability there is a
female in the pair of frogs under two
different circumstances
circumstance a
the pair of frogs contains a male frog
this is the calculation the ted-ed video
wanted to
present what the story actually
presented was variation b
the pear contains a male frog because
you heard a croak that you know is
distinctive to male frogs
it might seem to you that variations a
and b
are going to be the same in either case
you know there's one mil frog in the
pair
but the detail that you heard the croak
of the frog actually changes the
probability
so in order to explain why i'm going to
go over the classic probability problem
that this is based on
the boy or girl paradox
imagine mr jones has two children
you want to know the probability that he
has one girl
under two different variations
variation a he has a boy
variation b he has a boy born on tuesday
it seems like these two variations would
have the same probability
but let's go over the calculation to see
why it's actually different in a and b
so variation a
let's consider mr jones having two
children what's the sample space
we know that he could have two boys
we know he could have a boy and a girl
he could have a girl and a boy or he
could have two girls these are four
events and they're equally likely to
happen if we assume the probability of
having a boy and a girl is equal
if we know that he has a boy
the event that he has two girls is not
possible
so we have a new sample space
in which there are three different
events he has two boys a boy and a girl
or a girl and a boy and these are
equally likely events
what is the probability that he has a
girl in this new sample space
the events boy girl and girl boy are
equally likely
there are two events in which he has a
girl out of three
therefore the probability he has a girl
if we know he has a boy is equal to
two-thirds
now let's consider the other variation
what would happen if we know he has a
boy that's born on a tuesday now this
seems like it shouldn't affect the
calculation
knowing he has a boy obviously the boy
would have to be born on some day of the
week so whether he's born on tuesday or
any other day shouldn't matter
however the fact we learned that the boy
is born on a tuesday does change our
sample space
so we know there are only three possible
pairs of genders it could either be boy
boy boy girl or girl boy he can't have
two girls because we know that he has a
boy
we also know that the boy is born on a
tuesday so let's indicate the days of
the week by a numerical code zero
equaling sunday
one equaling monday and counting up all
the way until six equaling saturday
we'll write the day of the week that a
child is born using a subscript
so what is our sample space now
for boys that are boys and girls that
are born on different days of the week
we need to define the events that are
equally likely to happen
if he has two boys it's possible that
the first child was born on a tuesday
and the second child was equally likely
to be born on any of the other any of
the seven days of the week
it could also be that the older child is
born on a tuesday and the
the other child is born on any of the
days of the week equally likely to
happen
if he has a boy girl we know the boy has
to be born on a tuesday and the girl can
be born on any days of the week and
similarly for our last case
there's one thing to consider here
actually
we've written down
b2b2 twice
we need to remove this so that we're
only considering
equally likely events
we now have a list of 27 equally likely
events in our sample space
out of these
seven plus seven involve mr jones having
a girl
therefore we can calculate the
probability has a girl is 14 divided by
27 which is approximately 52 percent and
this is closer to our intuition that
when he has two children we suspect that
it's equally likely knowing that one is
a boy that the other could be a girl is
almost 50 percent
so now let's relate that to the ted ed
frog riddle
the video presented the calculation for
variation a
however
they actually present to the story of
variation b and that's going to be
similar to the boy or girl paradox
knowing that the boy was born on a
tuesday so let's go through this
calculation
we know that if we have two frogs
they can either be male male male female
female male or female female
if we know that there is a male frog in
the pair
we remove the female female pair and we
end up with a new sample space of three
equally likely events male male male
female and female male
in two of these events
there is a female
so we can calculate the probability
there's a female is equal to two divided
by three
now this is the probability that's
presented in the ted ed video and it
would be true if you knew that in a pair
of frogs there's a male frog you learn
that by random chance
however the ted-ed video presented the
variation that you know that there's a
male frog because you heard a croak so
now we have to specify a sample space
that involves the male frogs croaking
we know that there are three different
gender pairs that are possible male male
male female or female male
let's indicate a subscript of one if we
know that the frog croaks and zero if
the frog does not croak
we have to consider the sample space of
equally likely events
it could be that the first mill frog
croaked in a male male pair it could be
that the second male frog croaked in the
male male pair
or in the male and female pairs we would
have that the male frog is croaking
the video doesn't tell us actually
anything about the probability that male
and female frogs are croaking
so we're going to assume that these are
all equally likely events
the reason we have two different pairs
of male male frogs here is that either
frog could be croaking
so if we consider this sample space of
equally likely events the probability
that we have a female they're two
different events out of four so that
means the probability is equal to two
divided by four which is one-half
so summarizing the ted ed frog video
actually present they wanted to do a
calculation for variation a
what's the probability that there's a
female if you know that the pair
contains a male frog
this would be a probability of
two-thirds
what they actually presented
was the variation where you know there's
a mill frog because you heard a croak
that's distinctive to male frogs in that
case the probability becomes one half
and intuitively hearing the male croak
changes the sample space you're two
times more likely to hear a male croak
from a male male pair than from a female
male or a male female pair so i would
suggest the ted-ed frog video as
presented should have a probability of
one-half
i understand they wanted to present
variation a now the key in variation a
is that you hear this information by
random chance
now that's actually pretty hard to do in
practice as you can see that's where
they stumbled in the video and made the
mistake they included the detail you
have to learn it somehow in practice so
very very often in practice you're most
likely going to be presented with
variation b and that is going to be a
probability of one half
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books i've
written many books about probability and
game theory and similar topics there are
links in the video description